good morning believe nation today's
message is generously served over to you
Keith Ferrazzi in retrospect in my life
I spent way too much time early on as an
entrepreneur pushing selling as opposed
to generously serving and once I started
to generously serve my product got
better as an entrepreneur so even in
that area of professional currency
people who believe that their job is to
sell stuff versus serve a community
actually don't do as well I think too
many entrepreneurs are focused on trying
to make a quick buck too many
entrepreneurs are focused on just trying
to get sales without really thinking
about the community that they're serving
the customers around them and I think
about this business here right we're in
a I'm in a business that I own right now
is Toronto dance salsa one of the things
that I've done is we have this TV that's
out here that people walk by and you
know most most stores when you see a TV
in front you're gonna see messages of
sales that they're having or coupons or
special promotions where ours has
nothing to do with that you walk by our
TV you're gonna see random acts of
kindness and there's a message on there
that encourages people to do something
nice or somebody else today you're not
gonna see sales on ourselves the classes
are scheduled you're gonna see a guy
stopping out of his car to help an old
lady cross really busy Street you're
gonna see a woman who on her 20th
birthday decided to do 20 things to help
people in her community
random acts of kindness you're gonna see
a homeless man take money out of his
change pocket all the money he has pay
for somebody else's parking meter
because the guy ran off and in Baker
parking and the homeless guy didn't want
that guy to get a ticket some moving
stuff and I picked videos that moved me
that when I watched I got emotional I
got a little teary eyed made me want to
do something better
because yes I want people to sign up for
my salsa classes and sign up for the
programs that we have here but more
importantly I want people to be moved I
want people who come and experience a
class with us to come out a better
person I want people who walk by our
store to feel like they're a better
person I want to give back and help them
and while so many people focus just on
the short term sale there's an insane
amount of equity that is built up in
having people be able to talk about you
right like give people a reason to talk
about you because you're helping them so
much and there is that this aside for me
it's just I want to do good you know I
want to feel like I'm making an impact I
want to feel like I'm touching people's
lives and I can do that through
entrepreneurship I could do that through
salsa I could do it through a number of
different ways and as much as I can help
I want to and when you take on that
approach instead of being selfish and
just thinking I need to make as much
money as possible then the world opens
up to you then that's when you start
seeing results in progress and traction
with your business another quick example
one of my old instructors moved out of
the city to a different city and she's
coming back and asked if she could use a
studio and what kind of rental agreement
we could work out and I told her you
know you're not you're not an instructor
her anymore but you're still part of the
family and as long as the studio is free
you can use it you know I don't need to
make any money off of you using the
studio it's yours as long as we don't
really else going on and you might look
at that in a business case and say well
you've lost an opportunity to make money
you know why did you do that and for me
it seems very short-sighted for me it
always finds ways to come back to me and
it's not that she owes me now but it's
if people feel an emotional attachment
to your company and emotional attachment
to your brand and emotional attachment
to you they're going to like you more
they're gonna tell more people about you
they're gonna spread the good news
they're gonna buy from you more of their
customers that is what you want
and so I'm happy to give up the
short-term immediate dollars because I
know what's always going to come back to
me tenfold and it's also just a way more
fun and exciting and enjoyable way to
live instead of constantly being
stressed out and I know that for a lot
of you you need to make money quickly
you might say what's easy for you to say
Evan but you know I got bills to pay I
have a mortgage I have a family you know
I student loans I'm kind of pay off I
can't make my rent next month I know
that that sucks but the path to making
lots of money is to providing lots of
value and if all you're looking at is
seeing the next person that you meet is
your meal ticket you're not going to
give them the real value that they need
and as long as you're being selfish and
closed-minded and only thinking about
yourself then you're not going to have
the success that you would have if you
were more open and we're giving more
trying to help when you genuinely care
about others and you generally want to
see them succeed and these people are
your customers and your suppliers and
your team it comes back to you in so
many ways that I can't even count and
I've I've invested so much energy
especially into the people around me
that doesn't pay immediate results
just knowing though that by them working
on themselves and getting better and
improving that I would do it even if it
had zero business impact because I just
like doing it it makes me feel alive but
I know it's gonna come back to the
business too right the skills they learn
the improvements they make will bring it
back and so if you're frustrated and
down and out and not make enough money
your business isn't where you want it to
be I'd encourage you really to think
about how you can serve others better
how you can provide more value how you
can care more about others because it'll
make you feel really good and it also
make you more money with the long term
so the question of the day today is how
are you serving your customers or your
community leave in the comments below
I'm gonna join a discussion thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events festive
the TV go